madame la ministre mme sheikh collègues
c'est ta vie cet amendement vise à
prévoir que l'affichage environnemental
prévu à l'article 1er soit un dispositif
unique
il y répondre ainsi aux préconisations
du rapport du conseil économique social
et environnemental de mars 2010neuf
réalisé par monsieur philippe dutruc
précisément la préconisation numéro 20
précise que seul ce dispositif unique
permettra à je cite d'un seul coup
d'oeil aux consommateurs et
consommatrices de retrouver les
principales informations et puissent
faire les comparaisons entre divers
différents produits et services le
season envisage notamment de s'inspirer
de la méthode ademe ou puff qui
recourent à une échelle a baissé de 1
très identifiable par le consommateur de
recourir à des logo indiquant le
classement du produit au vu
d'indicateurs haddock non pris en compte
dans la cvs un dispositif type qrcode
renvoyant vers un site permettant
d'obtenir des informations détaillées de
la notation obtenu les sénateurs
socialistes partagent cette analyse et
estiment qu'il est donc important
d'envisager de ce cadre unis dès le
stade des expérimentations afin de
pouvoir ajuster aussi bien les
méthodologies que leurs convergences
gage d'efficacité de cette mesure
l'uniformité du futur affichage
environnemental est donc indispensable
pour la carte et d'information et ouvre
plus sereinement la voie à la
généralisation pour tous les types de
biens et services
voilà ce que je voulais présenter on
n'est pas dans la loi de simplification
mais c'est une simplification en quelque
sorte
merci à vis de la commission apporte je
partage l'esprit de cet amendement qui
est d'obtenir un cadre unique pour
l'affichage environnemental permettant
consommateurs effectivement de saisir en
un coup d'oeil les informations
nécessaires à son choix toutefois il
paraît conduire à une rigidification
malgré tout du dispositif tel que nous
l'avons voté en commission
en outre il il faut laisser de la
souplesse au stade de l'expérimentation
pour l'envisager
plusieurs types de modalités d'affichage
avant leur généralisation c'est pourquoi
chers collègues je vais vous demander le
retrait
sinon la vie sera défavorable avait du
gouvernement madame la ministre
merci monsieur président oui il me
semble que là c'est un peu prématuré on
a besoin de faire des expérimentations
justement pour définir quel sera le
meilleur affichage possible et donc
chaque chose en son temps des
expérimentations sont en train de se
faire il ya déjà un plusieurs types
d'affichage qui ont été testées je suis
allé voir notamment en entreprise et
quatre longues qui avait une proposition
d'affichage environnemental qui est déjà
dansé dansé
dans ses rayons et dont on voit
d'ailleurs que c'est fortement
améliorable notamment en termes de en
termes de visibilité donc les
expérimentations et sont justement pour
objectif de tester plusieurs
méthodologies et des modalités
d'affichage afin de définir le cadre le
plus pertinent pour le consommateur et
secteurs concernés par ailleurs on peut
très bien imaginer que l'affichage pour
le secteur textile et celui pour le
secteur alimentaire par exemple ne soit
pas forcément identique laissons faire
des expérimentations et on aura je crois
une réponse qui sera bien adapté c'est
pourquoi j'ai un avis défavorable sur
cet amendement
merci monsieur vivo et j'ai entendu vos
explications les reines les autres bon
je considère que ça aurait été une bonne
chose
je pense que tout le monde est d'accord
sur l'esprit c'est peut-être un petit
peu prématuré donc pour l'instant je
vais la retirer
on aura l'occasion de revenir sur ces
sujets là et et si vous le voulez bien
je vais essayer de faire les deux
amendements suivant que font l'objet
d'une discussion commune monsieur bigot
le 1378 oui il s'agit cette madame le
ministre chaque oeil
cet amendement vise à rendre obligatoire
la prise en compte des critères sociaux
dans l'élaboration de l'affichage
environnemental
en effet la rédaction actuelle malgré
l'adoption d'un amendement de précision
en commission n'est en fait qu'une
faculté
ce qui ne semble pas aller dans le sens
de produire mieux et de façon durable
les sénateurs de mon groupe du groupe
socialistes et écologistes et
républicains considèrent qu encore vu
des attentes sociétales actuelles
ce futur achat l'affichage ne saurait
occulter les conditions de travail dans
lesquelles les biens ont été produits
comment pourrions nous tolérer demain
qu'un produit bénéficie d'un affichage
environnemental élogieux si dans le même
temps il a été produit dans des
conditions de travail déplorables proche
d esclavage moderne ou par des enfants
de plus s'assurer du respect de la prise
en compte des critères sociaux
permettrait également de s'assurer d'une
concurrence déloyale entre les biens en
se basant sur des normes de production
identique
madame la ministre nous savons qu'il
faut éviter il ajouté
et trop de critères pour que le
dispositif reste applicable mais vous
comprendrez également que pour certains
d'entre eux et notamment ceux visant à
prendre en compte la dimension humaine
il nous semble indispensable de faire
cet effort dans la construction du futur
affichage de 766 qu'il défend alain
poncet mange
mettez-moi le chrono oui merci messieurs
président donc je ne vais pas être
redondantes sinon que de rappeler que
alors que les plus grandes entreprises
françaises ont l'obligation depuis 2010
est d'établir un plan de vigilance des
risques de violation des droits humains
et environnementaux que leurs activités
et celles de leurs sous traitants
induisent cette mesure législative n'est
toujours à ce jour pas totalement
respectée encore aujourd'hui des groupes
des sociétés aidées en scène va fouler
droits sociaux et humains d'individus et
compris d'enfants à travers le monde
tout au long de la chaîne de production
le respect des critères sociaux et des
droits humains ne saurait donc être une
dimension facultative de l'information
du consommateur et donc nous pensons
comme aux collègues que là on doit aller
plus loin que la rédaction actuelle de
l'article qui laisse entendre que
l'affichage de critères sociaux serait
facultatif au dispositif d'affichage
prévue par l'article à vis de la porter
sur les deux amendements
s'agissant de la môme en 1378 en
commission nous avons établi l'esprit de
la rédaction prévu à l'article 15 de la
loi geiq sur l'affichage environ en
vironnement talent qui permettait
d'avoir soins d'affichage
environnemental soit un affichage
environnemental et social il faut
conserver ses doubles possibilité pour
appliquer l'affichage environnemental de
façon pertinente aux différents secteurs
concernés
votre amendement pourrait également
rendre beaucoup plus complexe en réalité
le déploiement de l'affichage
environnemental alors que il me semble
que nous devons avancer vite sur ce
sujet
car les premiers travaux méthodologiques
ont été engagées il ya plus de 15 ans
compte tenu du fort impact que ce
dispositif en réalité d'affichage porte
pour orienter nos consommateurs vers des
biens vertueux du point de vue
environnemental
je tiens à ne pas en faire un système
trop dit trop rigide ou trop difficile à
appliquer c'est la raison pour laquelle
je vais vous demander le retrait ou la
vie sera défavorable
s'agissant de l'amendement 766 à
rectifier la vis je considère en réalité
qu'il est satisfait parce qu'il n'est
pas exactement rédiger de la même
manière c'est un amendement qui est
satisfait car les droits humains font
partie des critères sociaux qui devront
à mon sens est déjà prise en compte dans
l'affichage environnemental et social
donc je considère qu'il est satisfait
donc je vous demande le retrait sinon la
vie sera défavorable
merci monsieur le président sur
l'amendement 1378 qui vise à rendre
obligatoire la prise en compte des
critères sociaux dans l'affichage
environnemental
l'article premier prévoit déjà la
possibilité d'étendre affichage
environnemental à des critères sociaux
mais je ne souhaite pas que ce soit
systématique et seulement quand c'est
pertinent et pour définir aussi quand
c'est pertinent
ça me permet de répondre sur
l'amendement 766 rectifié qui vise à
ajouter des critères relatifs aux droits
humains à l'affichage sociale évidemment
je partage pleinement aux objectifs et
je crois que tout le monde le partage et
la france s'est d'ailleurs engagé en
avril dernier dans une démarche auprès
de l'organisation internationale du
travail pour accéder au statut de pays
pionniers en matière d'éradication du
travail des enfants du travail forcé de
la traite des êtres humains et les
formes contemporaines de l'esclavagé
ces travaux qui vont mobiliser cinq
ministères les partenaires sociaux les
associations vise à accélérer et fort de
notre pays dans l'atteinte de cet
objectif sur son territoire national
dans sa coopération européenne et
internationale ainsi que tout le long
des chaînes d'approvisionnement
mondiales de ces entreprises
multinationales et dans ses commandes
publiques et pour éclairer le champ des
critères sociaux qui pourraient faire
l'objet d'un affichage le gouvernement a
missionné la plateforme rse de france
stratégie qui doit remettre son rapport
sur le sujet fin 2021 afin de bien
définir le champ qui fera couvert par
cette obligation d'affichage sociale et
les moyens de le faire et ce sont
ensuite les expérimentations qui associe
des parties prenantes qui permettront de
définir le type de critères sociaux et
les produits sur lesquels un pacte
social doit être prise en compte et la
loi ne saurait préjuger évidemment des
résultats de ce rapport c'est pourquoi
j'aime et un avis défavorable bien est
ce que oui monsieur bigot dit enfin moi
je crois savoir que la france est le
pays des droits de l'homme jusqu'ici
j'entends ce que vous me dites mais les
conditions dans lesquelles sont
fabriquées certains produits la manière
dont s'est réalisé et la main d'oeuvre
qui est utilisée parfois m'interpelle et
je trouve que cet affichage permettrait
au moins une certaine transparence aux
consommateurs après de se faire son idée
donc je maintiens cet amendement
j'imagine que le 766 est également
maintenue allez donc je mets aux voix
d'abord le 1378 avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pauvre
qui est contre
cette égalité égalité 21 21
dans ces cas-là 21-21 il n'est pas
adopté et je mets au voit maintenant le
766 même chose deux avis défavorables
qui est pour moi j'imagine que c'est la
même chose personne est partie comme en
ont
un 2 2 qui est contre il est adopté un
amendement 343 de monsieur dessus merci
madame la présidente
l'article 1er du présent projet de loi
prévoit l'instauration d'un système
d'affichage d'un carbone score destinée
à éclairer les choix de course de
consommateurs sur les pratiques
environnementales des produits qu'ils
achètent
nous estimons que cette méthode de
transparence peut s'avérer utile et
qu'elle doit même être étendue notamment
en produits financiers
en souscrivant une épargne une assurance
chaque citoyen finance l'économie est
aujourd'hui il devient urgent de faire
la transparence sur ce qu'on finance
avec notre état et si nous ne souhaitons
pas financer des investissements dans
les énergies fossiles ou des projets
destructeurs de la biodiversité il est
important de pouvoir faire ce choix en
toute transparence
il semble donc nécessaire que les
personnes souscrivant à des placements
soient pleinement informés de leur choix
en la matière et ce d'autant plus que
les sommes en question sont loin d'être
négligeables
les encours des placements financiers
des assureurs par exemple s'élève à plus
de 2700 milliards d'euros en 2020 en
france il apparaît indispensable dans
connect d'en connaître l'impact carbone
pardon cet amendement s'inscrit dans un
mouvement de fond pour le
désinvestissement des banques dans les
projets d'énergies fossiles
récemment je rappelle que le
gouvernement néo-zélandais a présenté
une loi obligeant les établissements
financiers à évaluer l'impact de leur
activité sur le climat ne restons pas à
la traîne la france doit elle aussi
permet de cette transparence en matière
financière
éclairer au mieux le choix des citoyens
consommateurs dans tous leurs choix
stella le but de cet amendement
merci merci et l'avis de la commission
cet amendement en réalité satisfait
chers collègues car rien n'empêche dans
la rédaction travailler en commissions
de prévoir un affichage environnemental
pour les produits financiers départ
d'assurance et de placement bien sûr je
partage votre objectif sur le fond et je
trouve même l'idée intéressante mais je
ne suis pas favorable à l'introduction
d'une précision spécifique pour ces
produits et services financiers
alors que nous avons cherché en
commission a construit et d'actions
communes pour l'ensemble des secteurs
qui prenne en compte toutes les
spécificités donc l'amendement est
satisfait
si vous ne le retire et pas je donnerai
un avis défavorable
l'avis du gouvernement merci mais la
présidente évidemment je partage votre
souhait de mieux informer les épargnants
pour guider leur choix d'investissement
vers des produits plus durables sur le
plan environnemental
dans ce cadre je profite de cette
opportunité pour vous indiquer que la
commission européenne oeuvre en ce sens
par l'intermédiaire du règlement
européen sur le reporting de durabilité
des acteurs financiers ou règlement dit
sf dr en effet celui-ci prévoit que des
acteurs financiers divulgués l'impact de
leurs produits financiers sur
l'environnement notamment à travers du
reporting d'indicateurs clés de
performance environnementaux émissions
de gaz à effet de serre biodiversité
déchets en outre la commission a créé
actuellement le premier système de
classification des activités économiques
durables à travers la taxonomie celle ci
sera utilisée notamment dans le cadre de
l'éco label européen pour les produits
financiers et permettra de garantir aux
investisseurs individuels et
consommateurs la qualité
environnementale de leurs
investissements et cette taxonomie
obligent également les acteurs
financiers à divulguer sous certaines
conditions la parte durable sur le plan
environnemental de leurs produits
financiers commercialisée comme tel
c'est la raison pour laquelle concerne
votre amendement est satisfait je suis
défavorable
je vais donc que mettre aux voix cet
amendement 343 qui est pour et qui est
contre il n'est pas adopté trois
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
décision commune le 210 rectifié madame
verte vous avez la parole
merci madame la présidente la nouvelle
rédaction de l'article 1er qui est issu
des discussions en commission établit
une hiérarchie entre les modes
d'affichage d'abord l'affichage physique
puis en cas d'impossibilité technique
l'affichage dématérialisée or la
possibilité pour les professionnels de
recourir à la dématérialisation de
l'affichage de l'impact environnemental
est essentiel pour les raisons suivantes
l'affichage physique
donner lieu une multiplication des
supports d'information sur les produits
une augmentation de leur taille
notamment pour les petits produits
cela serait contraire à l'objectif même
du législateur l'affichage
dématérialisée permettra une information
plus complète du consommateur plus
pédagogue sur l'impact environnemental
du produit par ailleurs les informations
disponibles seront plus facilement
actualisables ce qui est nécessaire du
fait de la grande flexibilité des
chaînes de production actuelle enfin
l'obligation d'apposer de nouvelles
mentions physiquement sur les produits
propres au marché français créerait des
contraintes logistiques des coûts
additionnelles significatives sur des
chaînes de production mondiale aussi je
vous propose mes chers collègues de
revenir à l'adisq à la rédaction issue
des discussions en séance publique à
l'assemblée nationale qui établissait
une égalité des modes d'affichage
quel est l'avis de la commission sans
pardon sms en dix ans comme une tresse
le monsieur bigot pour le suivant
présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues comme ce fut le cas lors
de la loi rejette les sénateurs
socialistes écologistes et républicains
sont défavorables à la possibilité de
dématérialiser l'affichage
environnemental prévu à l'article 1er
nous estimons indispensable de permettre
aux consommateurs d'avoir un accès
direct en magasin notamment à cet
affichage sans aide de l'obligation de
passer par des plateformes électroniques
ou des applications de smartphones que
tout un chacun ne possèdent pas
forcément il s'agit de rendre cet
affichage le plus universel possible car
même si la très grande majorité des
français disposent aujourd'hui d'un
smartphone nous savons également que la
maîtrise de son utilisation est pour le
moins très inégale la rédaction retenue
par le rapporteur en commission est
certes plus encadrante que le texte
initial du gouvernement en indiquant que
le recours à d'autres procédés se fera
encore d'impossibilité technique de
procéder par voie de marquage
d'étiquetage
toutefois nous nous interrogeons
justement sur les réelles
impossibilité technique qui pourrait
exister nous craignons que l'inscription
de cette exception dans la loi génère
des dérives et soit la porte ouverte à
toutes les dérogations possibles rendant
en conséquence le dispositif très opaque
le présent amendement vise donc à
prévoir que l'affichage environnemental
devra se faire par voie de marquage ou
d'étiquetage
merci pour le 1049 monsieur pieds noirs
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues comme
c'était évoqué l'article 1er été réécrit
par le sénat pour viser ce que
l'affichage environnemental soit
effectuée par voie de marquage ou
d'étiquetage ou tout autre procédé
adapté seulement en cas d'impossibilité
technique de procéder par voie
dématérialisée d'un marquage ou
d'étiquetage
cette rédaction ont semble-t-il ne
permet pas d'envisager un mode de
communication donc dématérialisée et
risque de noyer la formation destinée
aux consommateurs parmi d'autres
informations
contrairement à ce que vient de dire mon
collègue de maine et loire non estimant
qu' il faut apporter de la souplesse
dans la possibilité de réaliser cet
étiquetage donc c'est la rédaction de
cet amendement qui va dans ce sens quel
est l'avis de la commission sur ces
trois amendements alors sur l'amendement
210 rectifier c'est un amendement qui
revient sur la rédaction travaillée
adopté par la commission
je considère qu'il faut réaliser cet
affichage en priorité par voie de
marquage et d'étiquetage pour deux
raisons d'abord l'objectif de cet
affichage est d'être facilement
accessible et visible pour le
consommateur pour orienter efficacement
ses choix le marquage et l'étiquetage
sont plus appropriés pour cet objectif
je jouis ensuite je suis
particulièrement sensible aux enjeux de
l'inclusion numérique à la fois d'un
point de vue générationnel et
géographique
or le risque est de généraliser
l'affichage environnemental par voie
électronique en laissant ses
possibilités donc de créer une fracture
entre deux catégories de consommateurs
ceux qui maîtrisent les outils
numériques et ceux qui ne les maîtrisent
pas la rédaction de commission laisse la
possibilité toutefois de procéder par
toute autre voie d' que
harkat et étiquetage en cas
d'impossibilité technique
cela me semble être le bon équilibre en
fait pour arriver à l'objectif donc je
demande le retrait à des faux avis
défavorable s'agissant de la maman de
sang ni ce nom le suivant ce n'est pas
celui-là
si l'amendement 1379 pardon celui-ci cet
amendement est dans la logique inverse à
celui que nous venons de voir en réalité
puisque là dessus je pense que la
rédaction de commission est un bon
équilibre
un bon compromis entre refuser
totalement l'étiquetage par voie
électronique sauf en cas d'impossibilité
technique et de généraliser un affichage
par rod marquage d'étiquetage sans
laisser de possibilité d'adaptation ça
me paraît beaucoup trop restrictif et
donc je vais vous demander le retrait a
des faux avis défavorable est donc le
dernier c'est le 1049 le 1049 même avis
que les deux précédents
je souhaite m'en tenir à la rédaction de
commissions qui étaient équilibrés
laisse ouvert évidemment l'affichage la
possibilité d'un affichage par voie
électronique
en cas d'impossibilité et mes demandes
prioritairement un affichage évidemment
paroisse de marquage étiquetage donc là
aussi je vais demander le retrait sinon
la vie sera défavorable
quel est l'avis du gouvernement merci
madame la présidente
sur cette question de la de du type
d'affichage environnemental
nous sommes plutôt favorable à ne pas
trop contraindre dans la loi le règle le
décrit permettra ensuite de définir là
où il est plus adapté de choisir un
m un étiquetage physique ou un
étiquetage électronique
c'est pourquoi la rédaction qui est
proposée sur le 210 rectifié nous paraît
être une bonne rédaction et donc j
émettraient un avis favorable celui de
le 1379 en fait empêche même la
possibilité de fait de recourir à
l'affichage électronique c'est quand
même dommage de se priver de cet apport
surtout si comme vous venez de l'adopter
vous voulez mettre 2d de plus en plus
d'informations dans cet affichage
environnemental à un moment si on peut
pas les mettre par voie électronique
toutes ces informations là moi je ne
sais pas comment on va pouvoir faire
tenir ça sur une étiquette donc cette
pas c'est pourquoi j'ai mis un avis
défavorable au 1379 et le 1049 rectifier
c'est un avis c'est une demande de
retrait au profit du 210 puisque c'est à
peu près la même idée bien j'avais donc
messieurs pied noir donne la parole mais
là le président tu pour tenir compte de
l'expression de la ministre à l'instant
je vais retirer l'amendement 1049 au
profit du 210 rectifier je vais donc
mettre on voit d'abord le 210 qui a reçu
un avis défavorable des demandes de
retrait et un avis défavorable de la
commission et un avis favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre et adopté j'attends
il n'est pas adoptée jeu mais on voit
maintenant le 13 mai 1979 qui a reçu un
avis défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
on recommence est-ce que vous pouvez
laisser vos ma lever tous en même temps
s'il vous plaît parce que vous a pas
échappé qu'il faut compter précisément
la petite
qui est contre on
il n'est pas adopté le 1608 de monsieur
bigot et ses collègues et que
l'information délivrée aux citoyens
consommateurs devraient être visibles et
accessibles sur le bien ou le service au
moment de l'acte d'achat
dans la continuité des amendements
précédent que nous devons que nous
venons de défendre nous estimons
nécessaire d'avoir un empire un
affichage environnemental à deux jambes
physiques et dématérialisées l'un ne
peut fonctionner sans l'autre notamment
pour des raisons de transparence de
l'information
prenons l'exemple du commerce en ligne
le texte en l'état permettrait à la
plateforme d'achat de choisir entre un
affichage visible ou accessibles grâce à
un lien plus ou moins évident pour
l'acheteur
la visibilité de l'affichage et son
accessibilité sont excessivement liés et
c'est la raison pour laquelle cet
amendement propose de cumuler les deux
conditions pour une meilleure lisibilité
de l'outil d'affichage environnemental
mission c'est un amendement de précision
l'avis est favorable
l'avis du gouvernement décidément non en
fait le fait de remplacer le mot ou par
le mot et afin de rendre l'affichage
visibles et accessibles par le
consommateur reviendrait à imposer un
affichage physiques et dématérialisés
pour chaque secteur
or il convient ce stade de ne pas
contraindre davantage le cadre
législatif les modalités d'affichage
pourront être définies par voie
réglementaire sur la base des
enseignements des expérimentations qui
sont en cours et en fonction des
particularités de chaque secteur et
c'est pourquoi j'ai mis un avis
défavorable à cette âme en 1608 qui a
reçu un avis favorable de la commission
est défavorable du gouvernement qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté le 1380 monsieur bigot
c'est vous
cet amendement s'inscrit dans la
continuité des précédents et recevra un
accueil très favorable bien connus comme
celui qui vient de s'exprimer comme vous
l'aurez compris les sénateurs
socialistes écologistes et républicains
sont défavorables la dématérialisation
de l'affichage environnemental en
magasin qui peut être un frein à son
accès pour tous mais nous restons
néanmoins favorables à la transparence
la plus totale
pour le consommateur c'est pourquoi par
sept ans pour cet amendement nous
souhaitons que l'affichage
environnemental reste consultable par
voie numérique après l'acte d'achat il
s'agit de permettre de valoriser les
produits de qualité en effet si cet
affichage se fait par voie d'affichage
ou d'étiquetage en magasin et n'apparaît
pas nécessairement sur l'emballage du
produit
si on bat la ji lee 1 le consommateur
n'aura plus connaissance après son
passage en magasin lorsqu'il sera rentré
chez lui or l'objectif de cet article
est également il nous semble de
valoriser les produits de qualité
respectueux de l'environnement il
apparaît donc nécessaire que le
consommateur puisse toujours avoir accès
à cet affichage
après son acte d'achat quel est l'avis
de la commission
la commission considère enfin je
considère que votre amendement est
satisfait chers collègues donc je vais
vous demander le retrait sinon la vie
sera défavorable dans la ministre même
avis monsieur bigot vous maintenez nom
et l'érotisme le 1290 madame avait
l'article premier porte une ambition
améliorer l'information du consommateur
de l'empreinte carbone environnemental
des produits qu'ils achètent également
l'avertir sur le respect des critères
sociaux d'un bien ou d'un service ou
d'une catégorie de biens ou de services
un exemple je fais mes courses sur un
temps limité comment suis-je lors de mon
parcours d'achat informer au mieux des
conséquences environnementales de ce que
j'achète indispensable en premier lieu
que cette information soit dans la vie
quotidienne à la fois facile accessible
et facilement compréhensibles cet
amendement entend participer à cet
effort de transparence en
à deux niveaux de l'année linea 6 d'une
part en proposant que la fiabilité de
l'information sur l'impact soit comme
consubstantielle d'une quantification de
celui-ci d'autre part en établissant une
priorisation de certaines informations
relatives aux impacts environnementaux
cette dernière existe mais il est
proposé que notamment deviennent
prioritairement pour les données
suivantes celles relatives aux émissions
de gaz à effet de serre d'attentes la
biodiversité et la consommation d'eau et
d'autres ressources naturelles
en effet l'objectif est d'éviter une
dilution de ces informations
essentielles est en quelque sorte une
dilution de l'intelligibilité il s'agit
en l'occurrence de données sur
lesquelles les consommateurs sont
particulièrement sensibilisés depuis de
nombreuses années à un porteur le fait
de hiérarchiser les informations
relatives aux impacts environnementaux
ne me semble pas aller dans le bon sens
car il faut garder de la souplesse une
rédaction la plus claire et épurée
possible la rédaction travaillée en
commission vise à lister les principaux
impacts environnementaux de toute façon
donc
j'émettrais en plus tout à l'heure un
avis favorable à un amendement qui
proposera de considérer ces différents
impacts environnementaux en fonction de
leur pertinence pour chaque secteur
considéré pour toutes ces raisons je
vais vous demander cher collègue de
retirer votre amendement à défaut il
sera défavorable la vie sera défavorable
l'avis du gouvernement merci madame la
sénatrice votre un moment vise à faire
ressortir l'affichage des impacts
environnementaux de façon quantifier et
en tenant compte principalement des
impacts liés aux émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et à la biodiversité
le projet de loi prévoyait initialement
la mention supplémentaire d'un score
carbone en réponse à la demande de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
notion qui a été supprimée en commission
ce que je regrette
il n'est cependant pas question de
mentionner tous d impact quantifié sur
le produit mais bien une information
agrégée et synthétique par exemple sous
la forme d'une note a b c d e qui soit
très facilement compréhensibles par le
consommateur et c'est pour cette raison
que je vous demande de bien vouloir
retirer votre amendement
à défaut sinon je demanderai leur rejet
parce qu'on sort de cette volonté de
simplifier pour le consommateur madame
avez vous maintenu
il est retiré quatre amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune madame
le rapporteur vous avez la parole pour
le 22 32 tout à fait mais merci madame
la présidente
cet amendement de précision vise à
assurer une information claire et
synthétique pour le consommateur sur
l'impact environnemental des biens et
services qui feront l'objet d'un
affichage environnemental en application
du présent article
il vise également à préciser qu'il sera
tenu compte dans cette information
agrégée des impacts environnementaux les
plus pertinentes pour une catégorie
donnée ses impacts environnementaux
seront définies en concertation avec les
parties prenantes des secteurs concernés
avaient du gouvernement pardon je passe
le suivant alors monsieur bigot pour le
13 80 madame fillol président de madame
la ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement est dans la continuité du
1378 que nous avons déjà défendu il
s'agit de prendre obligatoirement en
compte les critères sociaux dans le
cadre de l'élaboration de l'affichage
environnemental nous estimons en effet
que seul un affichage prenant en compte
la dimension environnementale et sociale
viendra répondre aux attentes de nos
concitoyens d'une consommation plus
juste et plus durable
le succès actuel de certains affichages
volontaires mettant en avant la juste
rémunération des producteurs est une
illustration de la tante sociétale en la
matière c'est donc l'objet du présent
amendement qui vise à préciser l'alinéa
6 de l'article 1 ainsi que l'information
apportée aux consommateurs prenant en
compte le respect de critères sociaux
madame ciel vous présenté l'amendement
de repli en même temps oui absolument
madame la présidente il s'agit d'un
amendement de repli donc vous l'avez dit
si l'obligation prise en compte de
critères sociaux venaient à ne pas être
retenu au sénat nous estimons néanmoins
nécessaire de compléter l'alinéa 6 afin
d'en maintenir la simple faculté à
l'instar de la joue opéré
en commission à notre initiative à
l'alinéa 4
merci et madame dumas merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
l'article premier précise notamment les
impacts environnementaux à prendre en
compte dans l'affichage les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre les atteintes de
biodiversité la consommation d'eau et
d'autres ressources
la rédaction actuelle revient à imposer
ces quatre éléments comme base de
l'affichage environnemental
or l'objet même d expérimentation sera
de déterminer les impacts les plus
pertinents pour chaque secteur
économique afin de s'adapter à leurs
particularités par exemple concernant
les produits textiles l'affichage
environnemental repose actuellement sur
deux impacts l'émission aga de gaz à
effet de serre et l'eutrophisation de
l'eau il convient donc de modifier la
rédaction cet article afin de traduire
la faculté d'adaptation de cet affichage
des impacts environnementaux selon les
secteurs
rapporteur votre avis sur les trois
autres amendements alors sur
l'amendement 1381 la vie sera
défavorable s'il n'y a pas de retrait
car c'est un amendement qui conduit à
complexifier fortement les informations
apportées aux consommateurs en prévoyant
un caractère obligatoire et je crains
qu'ils retardent la mise en oeuvre de
l'affichage environnemental pour
l'amendement 1382 la vie sera favorable
car c'est un amendement qui complètent
utilement la rédaction introduite en
commission et qui rétablit la
formulation de la loi à gec s'agissant
de de l'amendement 211 rectifier il est
satisfait par le l'amendement
2232 donc je vous propose de le retirer
autrement évidemment la vie sera
défavorable
madame la ministre votre avis sur les
trois amendements puisque madame dumas
vient d'indiquer qu'elle retirerait le
sens très bien merci madame la
présidente donc sur le 2232 c'est un
avis favorable puisque il
il permet d'apporter une information
agrégée synthétique aux consommateurs
dans le cadre de cet affichage sur la
base des impacts environnementaux les
plus significatifs le 1381 c'est un avis
défavorable dans la lignée de ce qu'on
s'est dit tout à l'heure puisque vous
ville voulait rendre obligatoire la
prise en compte de critères social dans
l'affichage mis en place et sur les 1382
c'est également un avis défavorable
puisque encore une fois ce sont les
expérimentations en associant est partie
prenante qui permettront de définir les
modalités d'affichage pour une catégorie
de produits données y compris dans le
cas où des critères sociaux sont pris en
compte
il y aura une vigilance particulière qui
sera portée dans ce cadre au fait de
disposer dans l'affichage lisible et
pédagogique mais il me paraît beaucoup
trop tôt pour le maître comme ça dans la
loi merci madame la ministre je vais
donc mettre aux voix
l'amendement de la commission qui a reçu
un avis favorable du gouvernement qui
est pour
pied contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
et les deux autres tombes par voie de
conséquence nous allons maintenant
aborder le 71 rectifié monsieur demi
vous avez la parole cet amendement vise
à ajouter une information sur le mode et
le coût de transport d'un bien ou d'un
service d'une catégorie de biens ou de
services qui sont visés par l'article 15
de la loi de 1905 du 10 février 2020 les
informations relatives aux modes de
transport et au coût de celui-ci sont
devenues quasi inexistante
bien souvent lorsqu'un consommateur
effectué une commande en ligne
ils voient s'afficher 0 euros sur la
ligne frais de port tout simplement
parce que la distribution et les
plateformes ont décidé dans leur grande
majorité de faire passer ce service
comme gratuits en l'imputant d'une autre
manière dans le coût global d'un bien ou
d'un service
alors que la mondialisation à outrance
des échanges a démontré ses limites tant
en terme de développement durable de
préservation de notre environnement que
de modèle social l'information des
consommateurs sur le coup et le mode de
transport d'un bien ou d'un service
constituerait me semble-t-il un
indicateur clé dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et le combat
pour la baisse des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre merci deuxième amendement
le 145 monsieur lahellec oui merci
madame la présidente prenable ministre
chers collègues
cet amendement vise à informer les
consommateurs de l'impact climatique lié
au transport et à la livraison des
produits
en effet si sensibiliser les
consommateurs sur l'empreinte carbone
des produits est un progrès le rendre
visible rendent visibles coût carbone du
transport permettra de responsabilité
l'ensemble des acteurs et sera de nature
à inciter dans les causses bong les
consommateurs et les vendeurs à
privilégier au maximum le recours au
transport décarbonés pour les chaînes
logistiques
est ce donc conformément aux objectifs
de la convention citoyenne pour le
climat merci merci qui est de l'avis de
la commission sur ces deux amendements
mon commentaire sera identique pour les
deux ans
puisque ce sont des amendements qui
partent d'une bonne intention mais
pourrait dans les faits conduira sous
valoriser nos produits nationaux dans
l'affichage environnemental un poulet
brésilien transportées par voie de mer
sur un porte-conteneurs de 20000 par
exemple aura un impact carbone et
monétaires beaucoup plus faible qu'un
animal d'élevage transformer et
transporté du sud vers le nord de la
france avec un véhicule utilitaire léger
ancien qui polluera davantage alors même
qu'il aura été levée dans des conditions
environnementales et sociales bien plus
favorable que le poulet amérique du sud
que je viens d'évoquer
donc il n'est pas souhaitable
d'introduire une mention spécifique pour
les transports qui conduirait à
déséquilibrer le dispositif
donc chers collègues je vais vous
demander le retrait de vos amendements
autrement la vie sera défavorable
madame la ministre mais ma ville même
avis mais ces deux mini vous maintenant
je vais donc mettre aux voix d'abord le
71 qui a reçu un double avis défavorable
qui et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adopté le 145 kippour
on va compter là
un qui est content
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté 5
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune 1982 madame dumas
monsieur je n'ai même dumas bien sûr
monsieur rejoint donc oui merci madame
la présidente madame la ministre chers
collègues donc cet amendement souhaite
intégrer à l'affichage environnemental
des produits agricoles sylvicoles et
alimentaire une méthodologie robuste et
multicritères pour informer les
consommateurs des externalités
environnementales des produits qu'ils
consomment et ce en fonction de leur
valeur nutritionnelle
nous passons en 1068 monsieur de rémy
est madame heures c'est de revenir
oui madame présidente michèle maintenant
reportage sur le collègue n'est pas
soutenu ces personnes merci donc c'est
dans le même esprit puisque cet
amendement consiste tout simplement à
rajouter une méthodologie d'affichage
sur les externalités environnementales
positives qui doit en partie aux prises
en rencontrant considère l'évaluation
scientifique
merci le suivant n'est pas soutenue quel
est l'avis de la commission sur 1982 et
2009 alors pour le 982 et le 1068 madame
et moi il/elle 1383 qui était collé
monsieur montaugé
oui merci madame la présidente dans la
liste chers collègues et les sénateurs
socialistes écologistes et républicains
sont très attachés au développement des
paiements pour services environnementaux
l'acronyme pse en agriculture on avait
d'ailleurs proposé un texte il ya
quelques temps
à ce sujet les pse je voudrais leur
rappeler répondre pour nous aux attentes
actuelles et aux évolutions nécessaires
de notre société vers modèle de
production qui allie à la fois attentes
environnementales sociales et
économiques
en valorisant les externalités positives
de l'agriculture c'est à dire les effets
positifs sur les écosystèmes pouvant eux
qui peuvent être engendrés par des modes
de production les pratiques agricoles
adaptées
les ps sans taire totalement dans cette
logique donc pour nous il s'agit de
reconnaître et d'encourager en les
rémunérant dans la durée les éléments de
biodiversité les pratiques qui
permettent d'améliorer la santé
efficacité agronomique climatiques à
venir environnementales et des
écosystèmes alors il s'agit de stockage
de carbone de préservation de la qualité
de la ressource en eau de protection du
paysage de la biodiversité et c'est donc
cet amendement
il vise à mettre spécifiquement en avant
les pse entre parenthèses à l'aligner à
la ligne à six de cet article il n'est
question que l'externalité
environnementale et je n'ai pas vu le
mot positif des externalités
environnementales peut être positive ou
négative et donc en mettant en avant la
notion de pse en affichant clairement
on précisera la chose et je pense qu'on
ferait on ferait ont fait un acte
positif du point de vue de la
compréhension par par les consommateurs
des conditions de production des
produits qu'ils sont amenés à acheter et
à consommer à porter quel est votre avis
sur ces trois amendements alors je sais
qu'il y en a qui n'ont pas qui ne sont
pas défendu en vain de le 1068 et le
1383 2383 n'est pas défendre non plus ça
c'est ce qu'ils ont été des présentes et
d'échangés de ses socios donné un avis
très bien alors pour le 982 rectifié bis
et pour le donc le 29 rectifié n'est pas
défendu et pour le 1068 rectifié bis le
commentaire sera le même puisque ce sont
des amendements qui tendent à introduire
un critère nutritionnelle dans
l'affichage environnemental pour les
produits alimentaires qui n'a pas de
lien même indirect avec le texte de cet
article par ailleurs les précisions que
vous proposé d'inclure sur les
externalités à prendre en compte sont
pleinement satisfaites car les
externalités visés à l'alinéa 6 sont
notamment celles relatives au stockage
de carbone dans les sols à la
valorisation de l'herbe et c'est toutes
ces externalités positives seront bien
prises en compte de toute façon telle
que la rédaction vous est proposé donc
je vais vous demander cher collègue de
retirer vos amendements autrement la vie
sera défavorable
donc là je
c'étaient les 982 rectifié bis et le
1068 rectifiée bien miss madame la
présidente
ensuite pour l'amendement 1269 je ne
sais pas s'il était défendue non le mans
vous et le 1383 cet amendement ajoute
une précision qui rend complexe la mise
en oeuvre de l'affichage environnemental
donc je vais vous demander le retrait
chers collègues
autrement la vie sera défavorable madame
la ministre monsieur dream i miev ou je
confirme vous retirer le 1500e donc il
n'y a plus que deux aviez donné madame
la ministre 982 et le 1383 d'accord
merci madame la présidente 982
j aimais un avis défavorable mais pour
les mêmes raisons exposées par manas
rapporteur c'est que en fait tout tout
est déjà dans la dans l'écriture du
texte et ces externalités sont déjà
prises en compte donc se sont
effectivement c'est un débat qu'on a eu
à l'assemblée nationale c'était très
important que pour un certain nombre de
productions qui sont des productions qui
ont une valeur ajoutée environnementale
mais qui pourraient du fait de d'un
calcul trop simpliste se retrouver
pénalisés par cet affichage la grâce à
la nouvelle rédaction il se retrouve
plus pénalisées au contraire ils sont
valorisés
donc c'est pourquoi je demande à un
retrait sinon avis défavorable pour 980
doubiste rectifier pour l'ami 383 c'est
différent parce que c'est à dire que là
il faudrait le mettre sur l'affichage
jeannette sur le fait qu'à chaque fois
qu'on rajoute des choses à mettre sur
l'affichage à la fin ça va devenir une
guirlande de noël le
cet affichage donc c'est pourquoi j'ai
mis un avis défavorable bien le 982 et
retirer également donc je vais soumettre
au vote le 1383 qui a reçu un double
avis défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté le 2005 n'est pas
soutenue nous passons en 1384 qu'il
défend monsieur montaugé c'est vous
merci madame la présidente madame annie
fréchette chers collègues cet amendement
vise à réintroduire scène à l'article
premier d'un dispositif spécifique
concernant l'affichage mental pour les
produits agricoles sylvicoles
alimentaires alors l'échec patent de la
loi et galim démontre une fois qu'en
matière de répartition de la valeur
ajoutée au sein de la chaîne de
production agricole les déséquilibres en
matière de rapports de force sont
considérables en l'absence d'une loi
imposant un certains acteurs économiques
peu scrupuleux du sort de nos
agriculteurs
nous devons donner aux consommateurs les
outils pour être eux mêmes acteurs où on
pourrait dire qu'aux acteurs des
expérimentations menées sur la base du
volontariat actuellement en matière de
juste rémunération rencontre un certain
succès preuve que les consommateurs sont
très attentifs à ce type d'information
donc il nous paraîtrait très judicieux
que ce ce point relatif à la juste
rémunération apparaissent sur
l'étiquetage pour faciliter la halle à
l'acte d'achat en tout cas un acte
d'achat éclairées avis de la commission
alors je comprends parfaitement l'idée
de cet amendement et il me semble en
fait très intéressante
nous avons eu un débat sur les critères
sociaux et j'ai entendu les attentes
pour les raisons déjà évoquées à propos
de l'amendement 1383 monsieur montaugé
je ne suis pas favorable à cette
proposition qui conduirait en réalité à
complexifier la mise en oeuvre de
l'affichage environnemental pardon en
faisant intervenir une nouvelle
dimension économique
toutefois c'est rédaction me semble
quand même bien s'insérer dans l'article
et porte encore une fois une idée
intéressante qui mérite d'être explorée
aussi je m'en remets à la sagesse du
sénat donc
je la vis et un avis de sagesse
gouvernement quel est votre avis madame
la ministre je comprends votre volonté
et la question de la répartition de la
valeur est essentiel et fait d'ailleurs
l'objet d'une proposition de loi dont
l'examen débute en ce moment à
l'assemblée nationale et j'ai par
ailleurs saisi avec mes collègues
elisabeth bornes et olivier grégoire la
plateforme rse qui est rattachée à
france stratégie d'une mission
spécifique sur l'affichage sociale je
voulais déjà mentionné tout à l'heure la
plateforme fera des propositions sur la
nature des indicateurs sociaux qui
pourront être pris en compte dans le
cadre du présent article et il me semble
cependant préférable que les impacts
considérée soit précisée dans les
méthodologies et non dans la loi qui ne
pourraient pas les listes et de manière
exhaustive moi j'insiste sur le fait que
si on commence à mettre ce genre de
liste dans la loi le risque on connaît
tous c'est que on oublie des choses et
que ensuite quand on passe réglementaire
on soit coincé donc c'est pourquoi j'ai
émis un avis défavorable
je vais donc métro voit cette amende en
1384 qui a reçu un avis de sagesse de la
commission et un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
non
qui est contre
qui sait peut-être adopté même billon
2009 merci madame la présidente dont cet
amendement présenté par notre collègue
pierre antoine lévy propose donc que les
expérimentations qui seront menées
doivent permettre d'évaluer notamment la
faisabilité technique d'un affichage
environnemental ainsi que vérifier la
pertinence de cet outil pour réellement
orienter les consommateurs dans leur
acte d'achat les évaluations qui seront
menées au terme des expérimentations
permettront également d'analyser les
enjeux économiques de cet affichage
et de conclure sur l'intérêt de le
rendre obligatoire dans certains
secteurs
l'objet de cet amendement est de ne pas
préjuger des conclusions des
expérimentations et laisser les
évaluations valider ou non le caractère
obligatoire de l'affichage dans certains
secteurs je vous remercie
merci le 727 monsieur fernique
ah non l'homme de main oui merci cet
amendement vise à compléter l'affichage
des propriétés écologiques des produits
de l'industrie du textile par
l'obligation d'affichage sociale et de
respect des droits humains
l'industrie textile et liang des
secteurs économiques mondiaux qui encore
aujourd'hui a le plus recours au travail
et autres avaient forcé les formes
extrêmes de production qui se cache
derrière la mondialisation provoqué ces
dernières années des catastrophes
humaines désastreuses
rappelons-le où nous en 2013 le rena
plaza au bangladesh ou 1138 travailleurs
et travailleuses textiles sont morts
s'ajoutent à ces conditions de travail
extrêmement dégradée de nombreux sous
traitants internationaux et de grosses
enseignes qui ont recours au travail
forcé en témoignent les déplacements de
milliers de ouïghours
organisé par l'état chinois dans les
usines sur le territoire du signal
notamment pour la production de marques
de textile quelques telles qu'adidas
lacoste gap nike puma unis tôt h&m il
est nécessaire de mettre fin à l'opacité
qui entoure les conditions de travail
des sous traitants ok les
multinationales de la mono recours
lorsqu'elles cherchent à baisser le prix
de la main d'oeuvre voir lorsqu'elle
organise l esclavage moderne
si monsieur marchand pour le 2107 oui
madame la présidente l'objet de cet
amendement c'est de ne pas préfigurer le
secteur alimentaire dans la liste des
secteurs qui feront l'objet d'un
affichage obligatoire
l'un des objectifs des expérimentations
visé au point deux étant précisément
déterminées les biens pour lesquels
l'affichage serait rendue obligatoire
il existe encore à ce jour trop
d'incertitudes sur les méthodes
d'évaluation environnementale pour
préjuger des résultats des
expérimentations
même si les travaux sont bien avancés
par ailleurs la réduction actuelle de
l'article rapporte suffisamment de
garanties sur le fait que cet affichage
sera rendue obligatoire à chaque fois
qu'une méthode suffisamment robustes
aura peut être construite pour cette
raison il convient que les
expérimentations ont été menées à leur
terme avant de désigner les secteurs qui
feront l'objet dans l'affichage
obligatoire c'est quel est l'avis de la
commission madame la rapporteure alors
sur l'arctique su pardon sur
l'amendement 212 rectifier c'est un
amendement qui revient au cadre posé par
la loi geiq
alors que le projet de loi que nous
examinons et la rédaction retenue en
commission sur cet article vise à
accélérer le déploiement de l'affichage
environnemental
je rappelle que nous travaillons en fait
sur ce sujet depuis 15 ans l'a déjà été
rappelé précédemment
s'il est complet que je pense que nous
devons avancer plus rapidement désormais
sur l'affichage environnemental
par ailleurs le déploiement de
l'affichage en france n'est pas du tout
incompatible avec les travaux qui sont
menés en ce moment à l'échelle de
l'union européenne sur précisément cet
affichage environnemental
donc je vais vous demander le retrait
autrement la vie sera défavorable sur
l'amendement 1241 c'est un amendement
qui revient sur la rédaction introduite
en commission et qui a conduit à
réhausser l'ambition environnementale de
l'article
je rappe en prévoyant que l'affichage
environnemental sera rendue obligatoire
prioritaires prioritairement dans les
secteurs du textile produits
alimentaires ameublement hôtellerie et
produits électroniques
ces cinq secteurs n'ont pas été choisie
au hasard puisque ce sont les secteurs
qui sont les plus avancés dans les
expérimentations relatives à cet
affichage
là encore je vais vous demander le
retrait sinon ce sera un avis
défavorable
je crois que c'était monsieur guerriau
qui défend des cet amendement
l'amendement suivant le 2105 rectifié
bis et monsieur c'est le même exactement
donc l'argument est le même le
commentaire et le même avis défavorable
donc demande de retrait l'amendement 72
rectifier il revient au cadre posé par
la loi geiq donc c'est exactement le
même cas que l'amendement 212
donc je demande le retrait sinon la vie
sera défavorable
s'agissant du mil neuf rectifié j'espère
que je les prends dans l'ordre c'est un
amendement qui est satisfait car la
formulation qui est proposée correspond
à l'esprit dans l'esprit à celle de la
linea 15
donc je vais vous demander le retrait
autrement la vie ce sera défavorable
il était défendu par madame billon
ensuite le 767
c'était oui c'est un amendement qui
introduit en réalité cette wii qui a
introduit une asymétrie entre les
secteurs concernés par l'affichage
environnemental et évidemment je n'y
suis pas très favorable pour des raisons
d'égalité de traitement
donc je vais vous demander le retrait
autrement la vie sera défavorable sur
l'amendement 2107 rectifié bis
c'est également ces mêmes arguments que
l'un des amendements qu'on a examiné
puisque il revient sur la position de la
commission qui a validé déjà la mise en
oeuvre prioritaire de l'affichage
environnemental sur les cinq secteurs
engagés que nous avons déjà cité donc je
vais vous demander le retrait
autrement la vie sera défavorable des
retraits par madame dumas vous maintenez
vous vous retirez d'accord ocado
calaisis madame la ministre
oui merci madame la présidente donc sur
le 212 rectifier il vise à conditionner
un affichage environnemental français
obligatoire à l'entrée en vigueur d'une
même disposition au niveau du droit
européen
évidemment il y à des travaux
actuellement au niveau européen dans le
cadre du programme il ya l'empreinte
environnementale des produits dit pef et
évidemment le gouvernement y participent
par le biais de mon ministère de l'ademe
et des entreprises françaises et nous
militons aussi au niveau de l'union pour
faire progresser l'information
environnementale sur les produits et
valoriser les travaux nationaux en
matière d'affichage environnemental
environnementale est en fait la france
de cette elle est en avance sur l'union
et ça va permettre aussi de faire
évoluer les travaux au niveau de l'union
européenne pour que ça aille aussi dans
le sens du résultat des expérimentations
qu'on est en train de faire quelque part
ça se rapproche de ce qu'on a déjà fait
dans un autre cadre avec le nutrisse
corps et qui a permis de convaincre nos
partenaires européens de l'intérêt du
dispositif
donc les imitent des initiatives
nationales de ce point de vue là des
initiatives donc sur l'information des
consommateurs sont très utiles pour
ouvrir la voie de l'agenda européen
la france doit se laisser la possibilité
de prendre l'initiative au niveau
national si le contexte européen
n'avance pas assez vite ce qui est le
cas ils ont encore pris du retard pour
la mise en place de 7 2 7
de cette législation mais évidemment je
vous rassure il n'y aura pas deux
dispositifs d'affichage obligatoires en
parallèle un français à un européen
l'affichage nationale se fera évidemment
en conformité avec le droit européen il
se calquera sur l'affichage européen
donc c'est un avis défavorable sur cet
amendement 212 rectifié sur les
identique
le mythe 241 et de 21,05 wii qui veut
supprimer la ligne relatives aux
secteurs prioritaires pour la mise en
place de l'affichage donc aujourd'hui
vous avez mis en commission
l'habillement l'alimentaire et g et
d'autres d'autres secteurs prioritaires
nous souhaitons revenir en fait à ce qui
avait été plutôt décidé au niveau de
l'assemblée nationale donc là nous avons
des amendements qui font un peu table
rase qui disent on ne fait pas de
priorité je pense que c'était une bonne
idée ça nous permettra de revenir sur
une feuille blanche et éventuellement en
commission mixte paritaire de pouvoir
réajuster donc je suis favorable à ces
deux amendements oui c'était ça c'était
les meubles au cir qui était rajouter
ensuite dont favorable sur ces deux
amendements sur les les 72 qui porte
également sur l'affichage au niveau de
l'union européenne donc même avis que
tout à l'heure défavorable sur le mil
neuf pour atténuer la portée obligatoire
de l'affichage
en fait il est satisfait donc j'en
demande le rejet le 767 donc pour rendre
obligatoire l'affichage social un
secteur textile mais je ne vous dis pas
tout ce que je vous ai dit sur
l'affichage sociale et je partage ce
qu'a dit madame le rapporteur sur le
fait qu'on va pas faire un point
spécifique sur un seul secteur
donc je suis défavorable et enfin
l'homme 2107 de monsieur
chants gens demandent le retrait parce
qu'il me semble que les amendements
précédent qui retire tout me paraissent
plus à même de pouvoir ensuite discuté
lors de la commission mixte paritaire
bien madame billon oui merci madame la
présidente retrait pour l'amendement
1906 ok merci monsieur l'abbé vous avez
demandé un parole merci madame la
présidente fils qu'ils sont examinés
tous ensemble je voudrais intervenir sur
la question de l'affichage
environnemental pour les textiles
ça fait un certain nombre d'années pour
celles et ceux qui étaient là où on a
débattu de la responsabilité sociale et
environnementale de nos sociétés
occidentales et de leurs filiales sous
traitantes à l'étranger on avait déjà
évoqué la question du rana plaza et
aujourd'hui on a encore au même stade
il est j'entends madame la ministre qui
lie fois il faut attendre que que tous
soient verrouillées convoi avec l'europe
nos populations en ont marre d'attendre
elles ont besoin véritablement que soit
affiché les origines des produits et
leur mode de fabrication
si monsieur marchand et donc pour
préciser maintien du 21 05 et retrait du
21 07
merci madame dumas je retire le 212
madame la ministre vous voulez vous
exprimer sur jusqu'à présent pour donner
une petite précision
moi je veux qu'on avance vite sur ces
affichages c'est aussi pour ça
d'ailleurs que je suis assez défavorable
au fait qu'on rajoute quinze mille trucs
dedans qui font qu'en fait ce sera
illisible et parfois je me dis que ce
qui rajoute beaucoup de choses sur cet
affichage
swans ne voit pas ce soit font exprès
pour qu'on ne puisse pas le faire
par contre sur l'affichage sociale je
pense que c'est très important et c'est
pourquoi nous avons mandaté la plate
forme rsa et ça va pas durer des années
c'est d'ici la fin de l'année s'est
terminée et donc on pourra savoir ce
qu'on peut mettre ou pas dans
l'affichage sociale et l'affichage
environnemental parce que c'est pas
facile quand même de faire une étiquette
environnementale et sociale en même
temps donc si on peut le faire d'un
claquement de doigts moi je serais ravi
je pense qu'on a besoin de ce petit
temps mais qui n'est pas non et je serai
très attentive puisque c'est un sujet
qui me tient à coeur pour qu'on puisse
aboutir très vite et sur le textile les
expérimentations sont en train de se
terminer et ça fait partie des secteurs
et ce sera certainement le premier
secteur où on aura enfin un affichage
environnemental digne de ce nom
harmonisée qui sera mis en place et ça
ça va arriver dans les mois qui viennent
monsieur le député monsieur le sénateur
pardon monsieur guay pour une
explication de vote
alors si madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues pour
défendre l'amendement 767 de nos
collègues écologistes
madame la ministre j'entends ce que vous
dites mais enfin même si nous avons été
un des premiers pays notamment après un
suite du drame de rhône-alpes et ça il
faut le redire à voter le devoir de
vigilance
quatre ans après on n'est pas au niveau
où on devrait y compris de ses grandes
entreprises françaises qui font appel à
des entreprises sous-traitantes dans des
pays dits à bas coûts sociaux et
environnementaux
on en est je crois aux procédures c'est
quand même on rame quoi alors évidemment
une question européenne vous avez raison
on va attendre il faut porter cette
question et cette ambition
mais je crois quand même que nous nous
avons à coeur justice sociale
environnementale comme un certain nombre
et il faut porter cette question mais
que quand même il ya des produits qui
font trois fois le tour de la planète
alors qu'on parle de roll
réalisé et réindustrialiser ça nous pose
question mais y compris pourquoi on le
fait de l'autre côté la planète parce
que les conditions salariales pour un
certain nombre de salariés à bas coûts
est intéressante pour le patronat non
mais c'est ça et quand même ce que vient
de dire nos collègues écologistes s'ils
ont le travail des enfants le travail
forcé d'un certain nombre d'entreprises
y compris des grandes multinationales
françaises nous interpelle vous voulez
pas entendre
mais ça existe c'est une réalité et donc
que l'on puisse évoluer plus rapidement
possible sur cette question d'alerté ce
qu'on appelle les consommatrices et les
consommateurs pour leur dire d'où vient
le produit mais y compris les conditions
sociales dans lequel se produit est
construit je crois que ça ça devrait
tout le monde devrait avoir ça à coeur
et c'est vrai que on a un type qui est
sûrement un ministre ou et d'ailleurs on
le voit bien qu'on parle de cette
question à chaque fois qu'on porte cette
question on nous dit soi c'est pas le
moment
et d'ailleurs on voit bien qu'il ya un
peu de mal entendre ce débat-là soit
c'est paul moreau cavalier législatif
soit c'est le niveau européen et donc à
un moment donné comme la france a été
précurseur sur le devoir de vigilance
nous pourrions être précurseur notamment
sur cette question de l'affichage
notamment sur la donne et social et oui
c'est une question comment nous
continuerons à porter ce combat
merci monsieur guay merci alors il nous
reste semble-t-il quatre amendements à
soumettre au vote si vous me le
confirmer au fur et à mesure les deux
amendements identiques 1241 et 2105
monsieur rios et monsieur marchand qui
ont reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et un avis favorable du
gouvernement
je mets aux voix qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas
adoptées le 72 rectifié monsieur
dominique qui et pour qui et contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le 767
qui est pour et qui est contre on
recommence
l es qui pour vous devez m'a bien aux
biens de franchement
bon qui est contre
je sais qu'un du but inné qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adopté deux amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
le 30 rectifié bis monsieur chasse un
merci madame la présidente donc
l'amendement mon collègue franck mais
non bill vise à interdire la publication
utilisation par des opérateurs
économiques et à des fins commerciales
de données chiffrées aux mets de
théologie visant à élaborer un affichage
environnemental qui n'ont pas été
validées dans le cadre de ces
expérimentations ou pour les produits
d'élevage qui ne repose que sur la seule
méthode de l'analyse du cycle de la vie
merci le 13 89 monsieur montaugé
collègues dans l'affichage il faut
garantir l'équité de traitement des
producteurs par rapport aux méthodes
d'évaluation que je crois que c'est un
principe important à respecter donc cet
amendement vise à attirer l'attention du
gouvernement sur les in qui est une
grande partie du monde de l'élevage à
propos des faiblesses reconnu delà de la
méthode dite de l'analyse du cycle de
vie et les risques que pourrait
comporter la mise en oeuvre d'un
affichage environnemental des viandes
herbivore sur la base de cette seule
méthodologie en pratique un affichage
basée sur l'analyse du cycle de vie
pourrait conduire à encourager les
consommateurs à acheter prioritairement
des viandes issues des systèmes les plus
intensifs en laissant de côté les
viandes issues d'élevages herbe âgés ou
bio c'est pourquoi au vu de ces
inquiétudes cet amendement vise à
interdire les initiatives privées
lancée en dehors du champ de
l'expérimentation nationale et pourrait
tout à fait transparent je précise que
cet amendement a été travaillé avec
interbev sait quel est l'avis de la
commission sur ces deux amendements
ces deux amendements sont satisfaits car
les décrets prévus au présent article
cadre l'utilisation de données relatives
à l'affichage environnemental
en outre il est pleinement s'ils sont
pleinement
satisfait aussi par l'alinéa 9 du
présent article tel que rédigé par la
commission qui prévoit l'obligation de
se conformer aux règles fixées par
décret dès lors qu'une entreprise
procède à un affichage volontaire et
puis parce que nous venons d'adopter
l'amendement 1388 qui sanctionne le
détournement des informations utilisées
pour l'affichage environnemental donc
comme ils sont satisfaits je vous
demande le retrait pour les amendements
le 30 rectifié bis et le 1389 madame la
ministre même avis monsieur montaugé
merci madame la présidente je me
retirerai volontiers cet amendement mais
je je ne suis pas sûr d'avoir compris ce
que vous avez indiquée par rapport au
décret qui cadrerait sais pas trop quoi
fait moi j'ai pas compris en tout cas là
ce dont il s'agit c'est de ces deux
méthodes donc basée sur l'analyse du
cycle de vie développé par des acteurs
privés tout à fait indépendamment des
logiques des études en cours
mené je dirais par parle par le
gouvernement mais par la piste j'ai
public
alors je suis pas sûr qu'on me parle de
la même chose c'est pour ça que je vais
pas le retirer et puis advienne que
pourra
monsieur chassaing vous maintenez aussi
très bien je vais donc madame le
rapporteur vous dire par les noms je
vais donc mettre aux voix
cet amendement 30 rectifié bis qui a
reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission du gouvernement qui pour vous
conter là
c'est bon pour vous
ils peuvent
les verts s'abstiennent jours qu'est
qu'ils étaient bons qui est contre
qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adoptée même vote le 13 89
quai pour pardon même pas lui même vote
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 8 172 madame dumas
de multiples initiatives d'affichage
environnemental fleurissent actuellement
et force est de constater qu'elles sont
prématurées au regard de la fiabilité
des données disponibles des
méthodologies d'évaluation
environnementale comme en témoigne
d'ailleurs l'expérimentation qui est
prévu par la loi geiq etc étaient
d'ailleurs encore en cours
l'enjeu de l'affichage environnemental
et d'apporter une information
compréhensible harmoniser et fiable aux
consommateurs en s'appuyant sur les
résultats d'une évaluation quantitative
multicritères et complexe cet amendement
propose que dans la tente d'une
méthodologie de référence qui n'existe
pas aujourd'hui les dispositifs
d'affichage environnemental volontaires
mentionne le caractère expérimental des
informations affichées
merci quelle est la vie
quel est l'avis de la commission cet
amendement est tout à fait intéressant
car il vise à apporter aux consommateurs
une information sur le fait que
l'affichage qu'il verra pendant un
certain temps n'est pas tout à fait
définitif
ce faisant il associe le consommateur à
la mise en oeuvre de l'affichage
environnemental en lui apportant une
information qu'il pourra utiliser par
exemple pour remonter des observations
ou des propositions donc je donne un
avis de sagesse du gouvernement alors
c'est un amendement
madame la sénatrice qui vise à définir
les modalités transitoire d'affichage
durant des expérimentations en imposant
de mentionner le caractère expérimental
de l'affichage à proximité immédiate de
celui ci l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est
d'encourager le plus grand nombre de
finir et d'entreprises à participer à
des expérimentations
il ne me semble donc pas opportun de
contraintes dans la loi les modalités
d'affichage du
la phase expérimentale c'est pourquoi je
suis défavorable à cet amendement
je mets au fond je maison voile 8,72
rectifié invite sagesse de la commission
est défavorable du gouvernement qui pour
ces bons qui et contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté le 13 87 monsieur bigot
l'alinéa 1 14 de l'article premier
prévoit que l'évaluation de chaque
expérimentation est transmise par le
gouvernement au parlement
si nous partageons cette nécessité nous
estimons toutefois que le gouvernement
ne pourra pas faire l'économie d'une
analyse globale à mi-parcours de
l'ensemble des expérimentations en cours
cette analyse devra s'accompagner des
recommandations en vue de lever
d'éventuelles difficultés de mise en
oeuvre de l'affichage environnemental et
donc faciliter à terme sa généralisation
il s'agit de s'assurer de la bonne
effectivité de la loi avec un
accompagnement accru les différents
acteurs qui mettront en oeuvre cet
affichage environnemental mission cet
amendement est partiellement satisfait
car l'étude d'impact du projet de loi
renseigne sur le déroulement des
expérimentations en cours
par ailleurs nous disposons d'autres
moyens pour suivre ce sujet les
auditions
de l'ademe des ministres des services
questionnaire bref on ne manque pas de
moyens il ne me semble donc pas
nécessaire d'avoir ce bilan spécifique
sachant que nous votons une nouvelle
législation sur l'affichage
environnemental qui prend appui sur
l'expérience tirée des expérimentations
en cours
en outre je rappelle que le gouvernement
nous transmettra les évaluations des
expérimentations qui seront menées après
la promulgation de la présente loi
c'est l'alinéa 14 du présent article
donc je vous demande le retrait avait du
gouvernement même avis je vais donc
mettre aux voix seulement 13 87 cas reçu
un avis défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui et pour qui contre qui
s'abstient elle n'est pas adoptée
le 45 monsieur boulou il est défendu
quel est l'avis de la commission on va
demander l'avis du gouvernement madame
la ministre
même avis défavorable
[Musique]
donc je mets tous vos voix c'est même
madame la rapportant maintenant que vous
avez l'avis du gouvernement maintenant
que vous avez un avis défavorable du
gouvernement quel est le vôtre avis
défavorable également bien je mets aux
voix 45 avec un double avis défavorable
qui et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adopté le 22 36 même la
rapporteure c'est à vous
madame la ministre favorable je mets aux
voix qui et pour qui et contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté je me vois
l'article 1er monsieur le président oui
merci madame la présidente avait
ministre la commission et tout
particulièrement par la voix de ses
rapporteurs examinera avec attention
toute particulière l'article premier
article le premier qui vient d'être
amendé et qui mérite un nouvel équilibre
et que ce nouvel équilibre qui en
résulte dans ces conditions on ne saura
peut-être envisager de soumettre la
nouvelle rédaction de l'article 1er à
une seconde délibération avant le vote
sur l'ensemble du texte je vous remercie
votre quand même bien jeu mais néanmoins
un petit saut mais je tissot mais je
m'en doute
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues l'article
premier de ce projet de loi a pour
objectif de faire ressortir les impacts
environnementaux des biens et des
services de façon fiable et facilement
compréhensibles pour le consommateur
cette orientation est encourageante mais
elle comporte deux points de vigilance
pour réellement apporter une information
fiable et juste consommateurs
premièrement et nous sommes tous
d'accord cet affichage doit valoriser de
réelles garanties environnementales pour
cela ne doit pas être copiées ou imité
par des industriels souhaitant mettre en
place leur propre affichage afin de ne
pas induire en erreur les consommateurs
je salue ainsi l'adoption d'amendements
que nous avons déposée contre votre avis
madame la ministre
visant à interdire le recours à un
affichage environnemental dans le passé
ne remplissant pas les conditions fixées
par la loi deuxièmement cet affichage ne
doit pas occulter les critères sociaux
nous avons porté et défendu les
amendements allant dans ce sens je pense
particulièrement l'amendement visant à
prendre en compte la rémunération des
producteurs pour les produits agricoles
sylvicoles et alimentaires en
introduisant de tels critères sociaux
nous permettant à cet affichage
environnemental d'être un vrai outil est
une vraie certification pour illustrer
la volonté de produire de manière
durable et raisonnée
je salue également l'introduction de ses
encadrements une ces critères qui
renforce avec certitude la qualité de
l'affichage environnemental et au vu du
début de ce texte puisque nous en sommes
au début on a fait à peine une
cinquantaine d'amendements on a examiné
a pas une cinquantaine d'amendements
nous devrions voter contre cet article
mais pour démontrer la bonne volonté de
notre groupe
madame la ministre nous allons nous
abstenir simplement madame la présidente
merci madame la présidente
et excusez moi j'ai pas j'ai pas
assister à tous les débats sur l'actif
qu'au premier mais je viens d'entendre
ce que le président longeau vient de
dire c'est à dire 2
entre guillemets de réserver le vote sur
l'article 1er j'avoue que je ne
comprends pas les raisons qui motivent
cette demande émise par le président de
la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire donc j'entends ce que nos
collègues viennent de dire puisqu'ils
viennent d'émettre le souhait de leur
vote
donc j'aimerais pour la clarté de nos
débats et surtout pour la prise en
compte de ce qui a pu se dire depuis la
reprise nos débats j'aimerais comprendre
les raisons profondes qui motive
le fait que nous ne puissions pas
procéder au vote
maintenant de cet article 1er le
président des poèmes j'essaye de
comprendre madame la rapporteure madame
la présidente je vais maintenant la
présente
j'ai sans doute eu du très mal
m'exprimer on va le voter
simplement simplement c'est un principe
de précaution parce qu'il serait très
mal venu
après un réexamen en commission de cet
article 1er de vous dire au moment du
vote qu'on n'a pas prévenu qu on pouvait
effectivement réexaminer et vis-à-vis
des changements qui a eu puisqu'on n'est
plus avec les amendements qui ont été
adoptées on est plus sur le fondement de
l'article 1er comme il était comme il
était adoptée par la commission c'est
simplement un principe de précaution
c'est pas du tout une remise en cause on
va le voter il s'est pas du tout remise
en cause
c'est simplement un principe de
précaution et je crois que c'est bien
bienvenue parce que c'est quelque chose
auquel on informe l'assemblée de se dire
que peut-être on pourra regarder s'il ya
une modification totale du fond de
l'article 1er voilà bien monsieur moto
gp monsieur bigot maire madame la
présidente
monsieur le président de la commission
des jeunes je ne comprends et de filles
comme depuis quand faut-il que la
commission s'exprime ou prennent une
opposition avant que nous puissions dans
le cadre du débat voter c'est la
première fois que je vis ça alors j'ai
pas une expérience extrême
je ne comprends rien alors je me permets
de le dire en toute franchise
mais ces bigots merci madame la
présidente
moi j'ai encore moins d'expérience que
monsieur montaugé imaginer le désarroi
dans lequel je suis moi je constate au
cours de l'examen de cet article qu'un
certain nombre de nos amendements ont
été rejetés que l'information que nous
demandions étaient soit une guirlande de
noël soit une usine à gaz
sans compter une forme de double double
langage qui qui est affichée par madame
la ministre notamment en disant que
l'affichage social c'est quelque chose
d'important et qu'il fallait en tenir
compte et puis toutes les mesures qu'on
propose dans ce sens là ils sont rejetés
donc moi je trouve que l'affichage c'est
extrêmement important c'est un élément
de la responsabilisation des acteurs
c'est la construction d'une
appropriation de la conférence de la
conscience environnementale chez les
citoyens
ça me paraît extrêmement important et
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans tout
ce tintamarre si vous voulez ou outre le
fait que je comprends pas très bien où
on va mais moi j'estime que il ya un
climat qui n'est pas claire sur ce sujet
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
proposerai mon groupe une abstention
monsieur guay je sais pas d'autres
oui merci madame la prison madame la
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur
monsieur le président de la commission
pour être plus clair
vous demandez peut-être une deuxième
délibération sur un fuyard a maintenant
comme ça au moins on y verra un peu plus
clair
dites nous ce qui vous plaît pas non
mais dites nous ce qui vous plaît pas
dans ce que nous avons pu adopter de
façon commune sur l'article heures et
comme ça au moins nous serons à quoi
nous en tenir parce que là nous nous dit
on va voter mais avec des précautions
enfin moi aussi j'ai peu d'expérience
mais c'est bien la première fois que
j'entends ça où on nous dit on va voter
un article mais avec la précaution impie
en laissant supposer que nous pourrions
y revenir je ne sais quand d'ailleurs
peut-être demain peut-être à la fin de
l' ensemble de l' de la loi donc dit
nous de suite
il ya un ou plusieurs amendements que
nous avons adoptée ici et qui ne
conviennent pas à la commission et donc
nous demanderons une deuxième
délibération sur tel et tel amendement
est comme ça nous serons à quoi nous en
tenir je pense que pour la clarté de nos
débats ça sera plus clair je vous
remercie monsieur le président mon tard
non mais juste pour aller dans le même
sens que que mon collègue mon collègue
je pense qu'on a besoin clairement d'une
clarification
on a eu on a étudié l'article l'article
1 qui a été amendé modifié mais je
dirais comme tous les textes
chaque fois ça se passe je pense quand
même pas besoin d'avoir tellement
d'expérience en la matière pour voir que
ça se passe tout le temps comme ça
maintenant on va le voter un point c'est
tout donc j'arrive pas bien à comprendre
cette tentative de clarification du
président de la commission ou alors
c'est peut-être qu'effectivement il ya
des amendements qui ne qui ne sont pas
satisfaisants pour la pour la commission
et qui veulent revenir dessus mais à ce
moment là il faut peut-être nous les
préciser lesquelles et nous dire de
quelle nature ils sont mieux le
président je vous souhaitez la parole
vous me l'a demandé je vous la donne
merci oui on verra aussi en cmp voilà
mais c'est simplement moi je tenais à
vous le dire honnêtement c'était
simplement par honnêteté intellectuelle
ne vous le dira il ya l'amendement 766
voilà on va pas leur mettre en cause va
pas le remettre en cause simplement on
votera l'article 1er mai que vous ne
soyez pas étonnés si en cmp il ya une
remise en fosse voilà c'est tout simple
c'est vrai ça très bien
nous allons donc procéder au vote de cet
article inquiet pour qui et contre qui
s'abstient deux amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune 1
présentée par le gouvernement madame la
ministre
merci madame la présidente
c'est un un amendement qui a pour objet
de préciser les règles d'appréciation de
l'origine des biens et de répondre à la
volonté qui a été exprimée il ya eu des
débats à l'assemblée et en commissions
d'éviter tout franco lavage notamment
par l'apposition d'une étiquette ou sur
un emballage d'un drapeau tricolore ou
de symboles équivalent induisant en
erreur le consommateur sur l'origine de
ce produit sans pour autant créer une
catégorie supplémentaire de pratiques
commerciales trompeuses serait ce qui
serait contraire au droit de l'union
européenne ni adopter comme règle
d'appréciation des règles qui seraient
différentes et donc contraires aux
règles de l'union
donc on a eu cette question du drapeau
français
quand peut-on la pause et caen ne
peut-on pas la poser la solution qui est
actuellement en cours de discussion est
une solution qui nous paraît être en
contradiction et qui ne nous paraît pas
d'ailleurs qui est en contradiction avec
le droit de l'union européenne et en
plus qui oublie le fait que les
pratiques commerciales trompeuses sont
punis d'un emprisonnement de deux ans et
d'une amende de 300 mille euros le monde
le montant de l'amendé peut être portée
de manière proportionnée aux avantages
tirés du délit à 10% du chiffre
d'affaires moyen annuel calculé sur les
3 derniers chiffres d'affaires annuels
connus à la date des faits ou à 50 % des
dépenses engagées pour la réalisation de
la publicité ou de la pratique
constituant ce délit il s'agit là de
sanctions suffisamment dissuasif pour
lutter efficacement contre les pratiques
illicites de franco lavage donc voit cet
amendement permet de rappeler cela est
donc de mettre une rédaction de cet
article qui soient cohérentes avec le
droit de l'union européenne
quel est l'avis de la commission pardon
il est en discussion commune excusez moi
avec qui défend le 129 madame delattre
bien alors je ne peux qu il est défendu
il est défendu bien quel est l'avis de
la commission sur ces deux amendements
sur l'amendement 2198 la vie sera
favorable car cet amendement permet de
clarifier les règles d'appréciation de
l'origine des biens et permet de
sécuriser le dispositif introduit à
l'assemblée nationale et que nous avons
réécrit en commission
donc nous partageons avec vous
les objectifs de mieux valoriser nos
produits nationaux s'agissant de
l'amendement 129 rectifier je vais
demander le retrait du fait que nous
venons enfin que je propose que nous
adoptions l'amendement 2198 je vais donc
mettre aux voix c'est un moment du
gouvernement qui a reçu un avis
favorable de la commission qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté il fait tomber tous les autres
amendements à l'article 1er bis
[Musique]